well thank you guys so much for sitting
down with me ya know we're really
excited to talk to you just gonna just
start off do your eyes just want to tell
me a little bit of how you originally
got on YouTube and kind of the growth of
your channel sense Nick and I were
originally located up in Northern
California we both have lived in various
times in the Bay Area San Francisco or
Berkeley or about an hour around that
area and I've worked as an actor for 10
years I graduated from UC Berkeley I was
up there doing the doing the camerawork
and editing that kind of stuff in San
Francisco for probably about five or six
years yeah graduate from SF State I
don't know we kind of hit a wall up
there creatively I think in our jobs
chris has been denied like I said acting
and doing that for so long I've been
editing and stuff there's there's a big
influence of like technology-based
companies up there and startups but the
creativity was you know kind of lacking
it was kind of draining us of our like
desire to do what we love to do which is
make stuff weird stuff and and we had a
good friend Chester see take a look at
some of our stuff that we created we
started creating stuff out of creative
frustration and we're putting them up on
the Internet not on YouTube and he saw
him Chester saw him and was like guys
are you doing this is do you put it on
the wrong wrong channel and we're liking
it would we always say this it started
out as this weird experiment and turned
into a love affair and we realized you
know YouTube was this great immediate
thing where you build a fan base and you
put your content that you want to create
out there and it's just been we've just
had so much fun you know are a lot of
our comedy or stuff that we do is a
little bit more of a slow burn it's not
necessarily the think of like a YouTube
jokes you Judy we don't really fit in
that category so we weren't sure how how
our videos are going to be received so
we weren't sure if that was going to
really fly and we've actually found
quite a receptive audience to that which
has been fantastic yeah it's a dream
come true we just get to play and make
weird stuff and do love to play weird
care so it's been really fun and um so
yeah about
few months in we are about almost 10,000
subscribers which was phenomenal we were
blown away that we even had that many we
thought we would have like maybe a
hundred and we kept growing and then we
got on internet icon which we were we
didn't really understand what internet
icon was God happened to more like what
is this and and we kept going kept going
on the show further further and we won
the show which was crazy crazy and it
was huge for a channel because it put us
in front of the audience at young MF
network had that right you had that
Chester had you know all the big players
like so it's nice and again like you
know we're just blown away that we have
more than 100 subscribers up grateful
for everyone yeah it's good really nice
and we can have a lot of fun well that's
awesome why did you guys decide to apply
to internet icon and what was the
experience like we didn't really know
what it was we just kind of did it and
we're like oh we submitted a video we're
basically we kind of waited out we
realized who is backing it the fact that
it would allow us to show off our
creativity and are like you know what we
do and it was down here in LA were like
alright so those are like three good
things let's just a note for it and see
what a straight I mean yum yum F which
is you know the the founders Justin Lin
director of all the The Fast and the
Furious is the most recent ones and we
got eight area Andy figments producing
and had another major movie and no for
us you know coming out of a more
traditional background it was great
exposure for us we thought it was a nice
melding you know of no traditional
Hollywood with you know the new digital
world and that's kind of we're not the
subscribers of you know thinking that
digital needs to kill traditional or
traditional you know spits on digital we
think there should be a happy medium
between both of them they become a
powerful force together there's
definitely a paranoid a parallel course
yeah so the show the show seemed like to
us it was like this perfect world for us
you know as youtubers do you know
connect with these people also do what
we do and if we got on the show you know
maybe get a little more exposure cuz as
you know you know being a youtuber is
getting your content in front of people
so it's like you know that sound like a
good idea but we definitely
but the show was until they pulled out
all of the cameras and said guys we're
making reality for the web we were like
wow though this is like a real coke okay
we actually just finished hosting season
two they called us back as hosts which
was a great experience in a lot of Ellen
I was a whole different side I whole
different ND on that side of it which is
it was nice like he would deliver the
challenges and I was the like mentor
character where I would go around and
help them just come back see you later
guys yeah definitely we have a little
release was nice we definitely wanted to
hug people a lot like we know what
you're going through it we know your
pain is hanging in there yeah cuz I mean
it internet icon you know if you watch
the show for your fan of the show I mean
it's very it's intense it's not it was
it's very stressful you know you're
doing these very complex videos that you
have to you know shoot and edit in the
confines of a show which has you know
all of those obstacles and hiccups that
are designed to create a show we had a
great experience I mean the last episode
I blew out my back and I was in the
hospital the stuff the cameras didn't
catch is the day before talking about
season 12 when we were contestants we
went to the emergency room and we were
there to like for the morning or so yeah
just like four or five the morning cuz
we weren't sure we're like I don't mean
I don't know if he's like severely
injured we're not doing I mean you know
the show is important but the end of the
day it's like this backed all messed up
yeah I couldn't really want couldn't
walk sometime over there it was just
like I'm ever calling the producers I'm
learning and I was like hey guys uh so
yeah we've been in the hospital all
night chris is backed blown out I'm
gonna be on the show they're like wait
wait what Chris was like I think a man i
think i can just walk around as long as
I don't have to lift a thankin yeah
kinda just plopped through the last days
was an interesting experience and I'm
glad we did as we won yeah it was worth
it and you know it's been fun and I mean
for us again I that's the cool thing
about YouTube you're you know you're in
this community that everyone you know
wants to work together surround each
other and you know you have I mean you
have the best fans in the world they're
like most supportive incredible people
out there that believe in you sometimes
more than you believe in yourself and
it's just it's great and we love
interacting with their
fans and and you know making content
that they're excited to see and I think
you know that's what I you know
ultimately we are storytellers and we
want to make crazy things but we found
that over time we also want to make
things that we hear our fans wanting and
stuff and yeah it's a fun interaction
yeah was there any sabotaging happening
on internet icon are you talking about
when we were part of season wonder when
we host this season two when you were
part of season 1 season one this weird
wonderful camaraderie happened I know
that the drama's sake the show dayside
got a lot of heat it's like I know those
poor guys I know but there really wasn't
any contestant to contestant like
sabotage I think it's just the nature of
YouTube and the nature of youtubers is
like you know we're all like a small
community of like indie filmmakers or
like your filmmakers no one is ever out
to sabotage each other in the real world
yes I think even in those confines of
that craziness it was still owe might
need a hand all right here you go like
it was never like no I'm gonna do that
or I'm gonna sit I'm gonna break your
prop I'm gonna you know make it really
wasn't i think that I need to know
itself had a few designed avatars if you
want to call them that but they were
just you know things to get the show
yeah me it's a show to contest so
there's like move in a certain way like
it's exactly they were just making
things happen for the contest so you're
all we're surviving this together we're
all friends because we're almost dying
every day did you guys have any crazy
party stories together when the cameras
went off all the boozing happened
honestly when the cameras went off so
did our like body with me it was the
most exhaust anything oh I wish it was
so we had so much more like interesting
drama to tell you I tried to explain to
people that when we were hosting season
two like you do not know what you're
getting set up for here like you're
going to shoot and then you gotta go and
write and create a whole nother thing
and it's like it is so intense like when
the day is done you're literally just
like I guess we're gonna try and sleep a
little bit I think everybody went home
and cried a little bit really
hotties are just like yeah what has been
your craziest fan experience so far
being noticed for it it's always
exciting but it's not like why we were
in this at all right so we're more the
kind of guys that like forget but I had
a fan I was at the san Cisco airport and
I was in the bathroom for a long time
and so what he does math problems
wearing it is what it is people I was
traveling and I come out of the bathroom
and there's a sweet kid who had been
waiting for me with his mom for a long
time to meet me and I'm alone out I'm
sweaty I'm like oh take some pictures we
are not ready for any sort of fame at
all we're usually in the bathroom coming
out blown out oh joy never coming out of
our names being like yes yes is there
any youtuber that you guys kind of turn
into fangirls for before we go to Julia
Smyth chestersee is like our friend our
our love our I'm we congratulate four
years and you know it's funny because
we've known him and you know watching
him in these different environments he's
the same guy he is everywhere it's
almost genuine person so we fangirl over
him constantly um but he's also our
friend so I've known him for years yeah
but in terms of guys that we have not
met Julian is probably the number one
and I think why Julian Smith everyone
loves him so much especially guys I
guess it's like he really treated this
like he was making set him up you know
they're like he lit things he had
scripts you know a couple behind the
scene things he did he showed people
like his his production and it was you
know who's treating it you know very
professionally it wasn't just a throat
camera up and I made a joke and it was
like now we're going to shoot a short
and they're gonna post it and his humor
and the way he goes about delivering a
joke is just weird we actually saw him
on a street corner yeah and we were
driving by and this is how this like
this is a legit fangirl moment we were
driving by and I was like that looks
like Julian Smith and say you know when
you're in LA you know it could very well
be yeah that nyx this Julian Smith and
it was a Squatch go through
Julian but you know we were too scared
to hunker didn't want to be weird but
yeah we also really like rhett and Link
yeah those guys are awesome that's
another person those are two other guys
that we saw driving in LA to that we saw
from a distant we're like there's
meddling that's the Bronco act cool man
exhales no they don't ever do nothing
but again those guys you know those guys
are just just absolutely you know
awesome and same kind of thing that I
bring a lot of production value a lot of
you know kind of absurdity together yeah
their stuff which we love wheeling yeah
we love and you know its cool the cool
thing about being part of the internet
icon family too is we got to meet like
and now work with it we're friends with
like Ryan Higa d-trix you know Andrew
Garcia all these guys that are you know
jenna Marbles read our man whose no
that's another one that mystery guitar
you're amazing yeah we're actually now
signed with big frame so we're part of
the big Frank family now and we love you
yeah chance for us you know and it's a
lot of fun because we're just kind of
like there they've got so much good
talent under their umbrella yeah its
kind like an arm arm's length away from
all these really cool talented people
yeah and sara is just she's such a
unique leader in that company and just
understands creativity and really you
know caught our vision of what we want
to do and is is not you know like oh you
need to do this and do that at all it's
just more like let me help you and you
know you know foster you guys to get you
to the next place so much more about
your creativity there than it is about
like you know well you got to do this
inside this deal and get this number and
it's just like Cree good stuff yeah yeah
so it's great so yeah those are those
are a few of them yeah they're great do
you guys see YouTube as a stepping stone
for you guys do you want to get back
into traditional media or is YouTube
something you think you want to pursue
long term we look at it as a as a as a
vehicle to get our content out there in
a way that traditional media doesn't
necessarily allow yeah but we still are
in love with traditional media so it's
like it's kind of this this thing that
we feel very strongly about that we can
build while having that side we also you
know can want to build a like cross to
over to the the traditional side right
yeah I think as long as YouTube exists
we're going to be married to it it's
just like what I imagined what maybe
Sundance was light years ago your
meeting you know youtubers day ah but
it's like hey what are you doing let's
make something looks everyone just wants
to create yeah it's just this really
exciting thing and there's not as many
you know we get a road blocks of like
you got to go get funding here you got
to go do this here it's like let's just
go out and make it you know they're
showing we're wearing it for the long
haul I love it we love it it's it's a
while if it's a lot of experience just I
think the fan interactivity is what you
know the ease of delivery of our product
and then the faint interactivity is like
literally yeah that's what's going to
keep this coming back yeah it's
addicting hey guys what's that hey um
why are you tying her up because I was
to ever get kidnapped too tied up I need
to see if I can get out of it okay yeah
this wait wait wait wait wait can we
read think the duct tape please no no
tomorrow sleep well I think this is
weird so at least cut a hole so she can
breathe oh by the way you guys today is
my French judo martial arts class final
so from this point forward I will only
be speaking French Jews wiesen home I
know what you just said but I sure had a
lot of catch-up for next party
no no no no no yes we all got home lose
it all restaurant lose it all restaurant
je t'aime beaucoup
you